I'm helpful advice with Bobby and kalila
Bobby and all my father-in-law's Korean
and a business owner in LA for years he
has asked my wife and I to consider
moving back to LA to work for him I have
a comfortable six-figure job where we
currently live but now he's offering a
job with a new company at more than
double my salary my wife and I are very
hesitant because it would mean I would
be working with him every day he hired
his brother a few years back and they
knee up they ended up not speaking for
more than a year I get along with my
father-in-law very well and this is an
amazing opportunity but we still feel
very hesitant and don't want to make a
choice out of greed what would you do
extra details we have two kids six and
one makes moving harder we would have to
live with my in-laws in the short-term
and we currently live about 12 hours
from LA you know I'm just you know the
only way to make it in life in my
opinion is to take big risks and a lot
of times you know the answer isn't easy
a lot of times isn't it isn't always
about you my completely sometimes it's
about will this give my kids you know an
opportunity down the road because
they'll make more money they'll get
better opportunities because of that
right or no I have a different point of
view about that sounds like a perfume
converse yeah I just I think the bigger
ring I don't like you you differ from me
I do
I think entirely I think the biggest
risk you can ever make is choosing money
over happiness that's to me too big of a
risk to take if you like where you are
now six figures is a great income for a
family of four mmm if you're you know I
don't know where you live but la is
super expensive and you would be making
double here but you would be spending
double here and I just think that that's
too much of it already sounds like you
have all these trepidations and they're
probably valid and you should
listen to unless you had a
seventeen-year-old kid who said dad
let's move to LA and help me because I
there's his career you know I mean like
if you were if you knew for a fact that
you were helping and boosting your
family in a way other than just
financially then I would say make the
move but it's just for financial game I
wouldn't give up the happiness that I
have now I would suffer through it I'm
gonna I'm gonna commit to my point of
view I think that's fine and that's why
you are where you are and I am RAM
you're in a better place no that's not
what I said financially you're in a
better place you took you bigger is
often times in my life I don't want to
start a fight with you baby I wanna have
a good life with you I I know but I woke
up today and I was a little groggy and
stuff but I just said to myself I want
to have a good life with you all right
so um I'll be better decipher okay I'm
always gonna choose love and family over
money always me too but it me too but
but baby I'm just saying me too but you
know it's like a lot of times you know
I'm not saying to do this for the rest
of his life but sometimes you have to
take a risk because by him moving here
and coming and taking Ritz he's scared
but he's gonna meet new people right
he's gonna meet people with other ideas
about whatever he you know and it just
opens up his world isn't what I'm saying
how do you know that his world isn't
open and that he's not meeting new
people every day and why the only place
you can do that you can live a very big
meaningful life anywhere in the world
anywhere to plant Ellie's not the hub
for that in fact I will say this I have
not met a lot of people since moving
back to Hollywood I met a lot of people
when I lived in Long Beach I met a lot
of people when I lived everywhere else
for me it's a little bit harder really
having deep friendships living where I
live now I have a Korean way of looking
at it I think that that's what it is
yeah you're all about pragmatism and
financial gain is important no it's not
even that it's in it and in and by me
saying it I realize that it's been
conditioned right you sort of go what's
wrong no okay
I do feel like you're right yeah finish
your thought I don't that's why I said
it because I forgot what bakery in your
condition
these are all here yeah understand let's
go backtrack okay and these are
different things that I've learned by
doing this is that when something where
I have a fart what I've been doing
trying to do is just try to be non
sequitur about it and just ask a random
question
so that maybe that's gonna trigger give
me that last couple of seconds that I
need so that's what it was luckily I
knew that alright so by beaming when I
now I know what my point was and what I
mean by being Korean is is that um I
just have a thing that my dad did which
was you know I'm opening up a store in a
different City you're not gonna see me
as often maybe at months at a time you
won't see me but know that I'm doing it
so that we can put food on the table no
it's for you I'm doing it right and we
understood that as a family so go to
Sacramento I'm not saying that that's
the best way to not come I'm talking
about what my dad did that I got was a
Sacramento my dad went to Sacramento to
do that for us right so there's two
different points of views but you know i
this is it seems it would appear that
the offer has all the bells and whistles
but that's to me is just an illusion
it's the illusion of being in a big city
if the illusion of having a higher power
job it's all an illusion I guarantee you
you will feel no different
not any more powerful by living here I
you know I I tell this to my sister
honey a lot cuz she's in the Philippines
she has four kids back home she's
married to a lawyer and she has her own
she runs her own business back there
right and she always has dreams of
coming to America and she's like oh you
know cuz she has her nursing degree
she's like oh I'm just gonna come over
and maybe we can just start a life there
and I was like well do you like your
life now she's like yeah I love my life
now like everything
has everything that she's ever wanted
you know the dogs the home the cars the
job the husband the life how's it don't
come here
he'll be miserable it's all an illusion
like I am NOT happier where I am now
than she is over there and I can
guarantee you that and I I would be very
careful about you know being swayed and
then looking at things that appear shiny
from afar cuz it's not it doesn't feel
shiny when you get there that's all I'm
saying you're right you're right you're
right but I need to win this argument
let me try one last thing okay
don't win it wasn't an argument I just
need to win my thing if you move here
dude I'll take you to dinner
honestly you move you I swear to god you
move here I'll take it to [ __ ] I'll
take it to [ __ ] morons wherever you
want to go whoever the best Bawa
whatever you want to know right with you
and your wife right I need to know what
the address you're moving into so we
have the facts that you are moving here
right I need to win all right so please
move to LA that's pretty good actually
better you have a restaurant offer for
him I can take you to a mom-and-pop but
don't move here because you know the
Colette is right what yeah I'm not right
I think helena is right I think you
wrote your cuttings right I want you to
be happy don't be you know what dude
you're right I've made too many
sacrifices for this [ __ ] [ __ ]
dream of mine it's not worth it
live your be happy mover the love is
move where the love is and I don't think
you should ever operate based on fear or
feeling like oh I should have done this
or I should have done that just move
yeah just move er don't move or the love
is you already have it at home yeah yeah
make your life big there you know like
wherever even if you live in [ __ ]
with a [ __ ] town
Bakersfield a lot of rich people
we went there Victorville Victorville
Victorville is not
bad okay you just make up a table area
asparagus game asparagus you really like
it
it's like tubes it's tube the green and
beers Bay they're called Sears yeah but
two tubes into it's like it's hollow but
not I don't like it I thought I read
this one interesting thing about
asparagus where all of us pee yeah we
have asparagus milling but not all of us
have the genes to smell it so it's not
that your pee doesn't smell when you eat
asparagus it's just that you can't smell
it yes and I do eat stuff that affects
my poo and pee who you are right and I
only eat it so that if so I can see what
the effect of it is are you into
digestible your non-date yes like beets
you know I eat a lot of what happens
when you eat beets
oh just makes my my um my pee dark it's
like you know what if you know Dark
Phoenix yeah right yeah when she's
crying but the Phoenix
yeah that's what my feet looks like oh
yeah and he drinks a lot of pepto-bismol
because he likes his tari [ __ ] yeah so I
like my poo really black and Tory if you
drink from the bismuth listen to me
right now if you want to change and you
wanted you want magic you would learn
how to do magic I'm going to show you
drink a whole bottle of Pepto Bismol
they don't do that
tomorrow your poo will look like dark
lava rocks like obsidian it'll look like
it's on fire dark black or lava rocks
remember like in that Chernobyl HBO
thing the [ __ ] that they found on the
rooftops that's what your pool looks
like also worth noting the writers have
tari shits you'd probably get checked
because you probably have internal
bleeding
that's right contact your local guy
about what that does happen